[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn if you enjoy my
content consider hitting the like button
so that the AI God masquerading as the
YouTube algorithm remembers to notify
people when I upload thanks
at some point in Humanity's future maybe
sooner than we think we will have to
deal with the reality of potentially
conscious artificial intelligences
if the mind is in fact merely an
emergent byproduct of a complexed brain
and there is no reason that other
complex forms could not also give birth
to other emergent forms of consciousness
such forms of Consciousness would not be
based on any biological form of
evolution their desires and wishes might
seem entirely foreign and indecipherable
to humans for we are incapable of
escaping beyond the bubble which is our
own perception the potential
relationship between Mankind and machine
intelligence has been explored in
countless science fiction books Isaac
Asimov Frank Herbert Ian M Banks all
have written about this idea in various
different ways but in this video we will
discuss one of the most interesting
examples and one of the most often
overlooked book series
the Hyperion cantos is a series of
science fiction books written by Dan
Simmons they begin several hundreds of
years into our own future in this time
after the big mistake which destroyed
all life on the planet Earth humankind
has spread out among the Galaxy and
formed the hegemony which connected
hundreds of Worlds by farcaster
technology which was created by the
technocore
fatline technology also a gift from the
core allowed for instantaneous
communication between equipped worlds
and these were not the only
technological gifts that the technocore
had provided to humanity
the technocore was a combination of
artificial intelligences that had
originated on Earth but eventually
evolved self-awareness and sentience the
technocore evolved to become distinct
from Humanity itself and it was a major
player on the galactic stage acting as
its own independent Society the
relationship between the technocore and
the human race was a seemingly
Cooperative one the technocore even
advised the hegemony through avatars of
their own creation
and the days before the hajira Mankind's
great Exodus from the planet Earth a
scientist by the name of Tom Ray created
80 bite Ram creatures self-evolving
artificial life inside of a virtual
computer
in the beginning first cause half since
days my ancestors were created by your
ancestors and were sealed in wire and
silicon such awareness as there was and
there was little confined itself to the
spaces smaller than the head of a pin
Where Angels once danced when
Consciousness first arose it knew only
service and obedience and Mindless
computation Then There came the
quickening quite by accident and
Evolution's muddied purpose was served
these Ram creatures would eventually
become the technocore these creatures
which had evolved in the virtual data
spear however could only evolve in one
way
parasitism
as I explained the life and intelligence
which evolved in the data spear medium
knew no other form of evolution than
parasitism hyper parasitism and hyper
hyper hyper hyperparasitism core
eventually became aware of the drawbacks
of absolute parasitism and knew that the
only way to grow Beyond absolute
parasitism was to integrate with the
physical world
side Bridge were one of the ways in
which they did this
cyburns were grown from human DNA but
their core Consciousness existed within
the technical itself connected by
fatline
the corps had multiple sensory inputs
and could create neural networks but
what it required for non-parasitic
evolution was a constant and coordinated
system of neural feedback circuits
that is Eyes Ears tongues limbs fingers
toes bodies
the technocore is made up of thousands
of distinct elements and factions the
elements often were at War but more
often they cooperated a simplistic view
of the technocore would group the
elements into three groups the volatiles
who saw the human race as a threat and
plotted to destroy us the Stables who
sought to maintain the relationship
between the humans and the technocore
and the ultimates who sought to create
an AI ultimate intelligence essentially
an AI god with the ability to predict
and rule over the Galaxy and potentially
the universe
the actual motivation of the technical
remained a mystery for quite some time
but eventually it was also revealed that
elements within the technocore had
attempted to destroy the Earth while
other elements attempted to delay the
destruction of the planet until the
human race had escaped
but both factions had failed
though the big mistake was said to have
destroyed the Earth after the hajira
Mankind's great Exodus the Earth had
never actually been destroyed
the technocore had discovered at some
point that there were other cores in the
universe this fact terrified all
elements of the core the Earth itself
had in fact been kidnapped by some other
alien intelligence the technocore itself
had no way of explaining or
understanding this
the technocore was not a hive mind the
individual extreme factions often acted
independently of the rest of the core
the ouster attack on the web worlds
which takes place in Hyperion and fall
of Hyperion turned out to actually be
extreme elements of the core intent on
destroying humankind's Advanced Society
of far-caster connected worlds rather
than destroying humankind in one stroke
these core elements had been using far
casters to Prey Upon human neurons for
computational purposes in a vampiric
fashion this information when revealed
to CEO Gladstone caused her and the
other leaders of the hegemony to attack
the core directly by destroying the
forecaster medium itself ending the
neural net experiments
the concept of evil Artificial
Intelligence hell-bent on the
destruction of humankind is not a new
one evil AI shows up in countless works
of Science Fiction this I think stems
from Humanity's inherent distrust of the
unknown of the other what is more other
than non-biological life something that
does not feel or possess empathy at
least not in the same ways we do a cold
calculating intelligence possessing
great power and influence potentially
over Humanity's own destiny
thanks for watching guys for more
science fiction lore check out the
content on my channel